Hi guys, welcome to video 17, portfolio
modeling. We've got a lot to cover in this
video with lots of practical techniques as
well as plenty of theory. That's all going
to act as building blocks as well for the
materials that you learn later in the
course. So let me outline what we're going
to cover in this video. And broadly
speaking, we're going to look at, first of
all, how you can download stock price data
and build charts in Excel.
Then we're going to look at how to compare
the historical performance of two stocks
in the form of a spread trade using
various different methods. So things like
using ratios or indexing methods. Then
we're going to expand on those same
methods and use them for calculating and
modeling historical portfolio performance.
So the spreadsheet file that I've got open
here is the one I'm going to talk you
through in this video. And it's got quite
a bit of data already populated within it,
which is there to help speed up and
illustrate some of the points that I want
to get across to you without necessarily
repeating processes or explaining
absolutely everything.
So this file is going to be available to
you in a more complete form in the
download section of the video so you can
always double check how everything works
as we go through and of course you can use
it for your own portfolios and your own
analysis as well.
Within the file, you can see that I've
color coded the sheets and what we're what
we've got open at the moment is that is
the black sheet.
The yellow sheets are where we're going to
begin. All of those sheets contain price
data for various different companies and
the sheet names have been labeled to
reflect the tickers for those stocks.
The data within those sheets has all been
downloaded from Yahoo Finance and for some
of the stocks you'll notice that the open
data isn't available.
It just shows up as zeros, but that isn't
a worry for us since we're going to be
using closing prices throughout.
There are about 20 stocks in total in the
file and for one of these stocks, FireEye,
I'm going to go through and show you the
process of downloading stock data and
charting it for analysis purposes.
The blue sheets are where I'm going to
show you how to compare the performance
between two stocks in various different
ways.
And part of that will involve learning how
to calculate returns and create indices.
I'm going to talk you through the
positives and negatives of the different
methodologies and then show you as well
how to sort of compare them at the end,
how they stack up against each other.
Finally, we're going to use all of that
knowledge to move on to some portfolio
sheets, the green sheets.
In those sheets, I'll show you how to
calculate the historical performance of a
portfolio of stocks in a couple of
different ways.
And what we're going to see is that a
portfolio of long and short trades is
mechanically just the same as a long short
spread trade.
All you need is for the longs to
outperform the shorts.
And if you have awesome longs that go up
and awesome shorts that go down, the
portfolio will be in an excellent
position.
So let's get started.
If we have a look at one of these prebuilt
stock sheets, for example, Paycom, you get
an idea of where we're heading in this
next section.
Basically, we're going to be obtaining a
time series of stock data, which will then
plot within a simple chart like the one
you see here.
And I'll then take it a little bit further
and show you how you can add things like
moving averages and trend lines to that
chart.
So the stock that we're going to look at
for this example is FireEye, which is a
cyber security company that trades on the
NASDAQ.
And as always, the first thing to do with
any data analysis task is to obtain the
data itself.
And when it comes to finding and
downloading data, and this goes for any
data, really, whether it's macroeconomic
or any tradable assets, you're going to
have to be quite flexible.
Data sources change all the time,
especially free ones.
And it may be that the sources that we
show you in this course become unavailable
or change over time, or perhaps the data
series themselves might be discontinued or
changed in some way, even if it's from the
same source.
And when problems like this arise, you're
going to have to be able to adapt to find
the new relevant and reliable sources for
your data.
The data doesn't have to be exactly the
same necessarily, but it should be fit for
purpose, given the analysis that you're
carrying out.
When you go about obtaining any data, the
priority should always be understanding
exactly what the data represents so that
you can make sure that you're happy with
using it for the analysis that you aim to
do.
So for this example, I'll show you how to
obtain and analyze stock price data from
Yahoo Finance, but you'll also be able to
use a similar methodology if you get data
from other sources like investing.com or
anywhere else.
So to download some data, let's head over
to Yahoo Finance now.
So I'm on my web browser, Google Chrome,
and the URL that we need to navigate to is
finance.yahoo.com.
And from there, once we're on the site, we
want to find data on FireEye stock.
And the ticker for FireEye is F-E-Y-E.
And so if you want to find that data, we
can enter that ticker into the search bar
at the top of the page and press enter,
and it will take us to a summary page for
that company.
From here, we then need to navigate to the
historical data tab and choose the time
period and frequency of price data that we
want to download.
You can do that using these sections here.
In this case, I'm going to select the
maximum time period available and choose a
daily frequency for our price data.
And then after that, all you need to do is
click apply and then click download.
The downloaded file will be in a format
that opens in Excel, and it's going to be
located in your sort of default downloads
folder on your PC.
You might also get a shortcut to open the
file from your web browser, as I've got
here with Google Chrome.
And if we open the file now, you can see
that we've got a bunch of historical daily
price data and volume data for FireEye.
And sometimes, as is the case here, some
of the data can show up as hash symbols,
which just means that the column isn't
wide enough to show the data properly or
it isn't formatted correctly.
So in this case, this applies to the date
column.
I'm going to fix this simply by
left-clicking and dragging the column
intersection between columns A and B, just
to widen that date column so we can see
the dates correctly.
And so you can see here that the data is
organized in an ascending order, which
means that the oldest dates are at the top
of the sheet and the newest data is at the
bottom.
And you can also see that the seven
columns of data, which I think will be
fairly self-explanatory to you guys.
They basically represent the open, high,
low and closing prices for each day.
And we've also got the volume traded as
well.
The only two columns here that might cause
some confusion is the difference between
the close and adjusted close prices.
Now, when you download asset price data
from most sources, you usually won't be
able to get adjusted close prices.
And this is actually one of the reasons
why Yahoo Finance is a preferred free
resource of mine for getting price data at
the moment.
The other reason is that it's just it's
ease of use, really, for downloading and
manipulating data in an Excel format.
So the basic difference between the close
and the adjusted close columns of data is
that the close column adjusts prices for
stock splits, whereas the adjusted close
column prices adjusts for splits and
dividends.
So let me briefly explain what both of
those mean in simple terms, starting with
stock split adjustments.
So if you, for example, have a stock with
a price that is $100 per share, let's say,
and the company then goes through a stock
split of two to one, meaning the share
base is doubled.
Then all else being equal, the price of
that share of each share will decrease to
$50.
However, nothing's actually happened to
the value of the company as a whole.
And in general, nothing happens to the
value of the stock each shareholder is
holding, since even though the value per
share has halved, they'll now hold double
the amount of shares.
If prices are adjusted for stock splits,
then the historical time series will show
prices based on whatever the current share
base is.
So in the example that I just described,
that would mean that the price series
would now show the price being $50 per
share, both before and after the stock
split.
And that basically makes sense because
there hasn't been a material change in the
value of the company itself, nor has the
event affected the value of individual
shareholders holdings.
A similar historical adjustment is made
for dividends in the adjusted close column
on top of the stock split adjustments that
we see in the closing prices.
So if a stock closes at $50, let's say,
and the next day begins trading X dividend
based on a $2 dividend, it's going to open
at roughly $48, all else being equal.
Now, this gap doesn't actually represent
pure market forces or the returns to the
individual shareholders, since the
shareholders will receive that $2 gap in
price in the form of a dividend.
So in general, for most of the analysis
that we do in this course, it doesn't
actually matter too much which one you
use, the closing price or the adjusted
closing price.
Since dividend adjustments typically have
a very small effect on overall returns,
when we're concerned with trading and
shorter term horizons, they are a bit more
of a concern, obviously, if you're looking
at investing or longer term horizons,
especially if you're looking to reinvest
those dividends.
However, you can argue that for the
purpose of analysis that involves total
returns or understanding pure market
forces on a stock, looking at adjusted
closing prices is slightly more accurate.
So the main takeaway here, really, the
point that I want to get across is that so
long as you understand the data, what
you're looking at, and you're happy with
using it in the context of whatever
analysis you're carrying out, then that's
fine.
You need to get used to being flexible
with sourcing and using data.
And so what I'm trying to do here is teach
you what to look out for rather than just
spoon feeding you a specific methodology
using one source, because otherwise, as
soon as something changes with that data
that you're using, you're not going to
know what to do.
So as I said before, this applies to all
data gathering and analysis that we do in
this course, not just, you know, the stock
prices or working with stock prices, as
we're doing in this video.
So with that explained, let me show you
how to create a simple chart from the data
that we've got here.
But first, let's copy the columns that we
have in A to G into this downloaded sheet
into our portfolio modeling workbook,
specifically into the FireEye sheet of
that workbook.
So you can do this by left-clicking and
dragging over columns A to G in this
downloaded file to select them.
And then within that selection, all we
need to do is right-click within it and
then go to copy.
Alternatively, if you don't want to go
through those steps with the mouse, you
can just use the keyboard shortcut to
copy, which is control and C once you've
selected all of that data.
Then we can paste that into the FireEye
sheet by right-clicking in cell A1 and
just choosing paste from the options
available.
Alternatively, again, you can do this with
a keyboard shortcut.
The shortcut is just control and V this
time.
Okay, so that's all the data in the sheet.
Next, what I want to do here is reformat
the dates that we see in column A because
at the moment, the dates that you can see
here are in a UK format.
And I just want to make things a little
bit clearer.
So what I'm going to do here is select
column A and then right-click within that
selection to format all the dates that we
see.
And I'm going to go to the number tab
within this dialog box.
And then I'm going to create a custom date
format by typing in this box here.
And what I'm going to type in here is
DD-MMM-YY.
And when I press OK now, you'll see the
new format in column A for our dates.
And hopefully that makes a little bit more
sense for certainly for all of our English
speaking viewers.
Okay, so that's the dates reformatted.
Next up, I think we should probably create
a couple of cells which tell us quickly
and easily what the company is that we're
looking at in this sheet.
So what the data actually refers to and
the ticker for the company as well.
So in cell I1, I'm just going to type
ticker.
And in the cell below that I2, we can just
fill this in with the ticker for the stock
that we're looking at.
The ticker for FireEye is F-E-Y-E, as I've
already said.
And similarly, in cell J1, so adjacent to
these two cells that we've just filled in,
I'm going to type in company name.
And then in the cell below that, J2, I'm
just going to fill in the company name,
which is FireEye.
Now let's move on to inserting a chart so
that we can plot all of our adjusted close
price data here.
To do that, I'm just going to click into
cell I4 and navigate to insert on the
ribbon.
And then click the line chart button
within the chart area of the ribbon and
choose a 2D line chart.
So once I've clicked that, you can see
that a blank space appears.
This is a chart area, and you can move
this chart about by clicking and dragging
it around the sheet.
You can also resize it by dragging the
nodes at the edge of the chart area once
you have it selected.
For this example, I'm just going to resize
it to roughly take up the range of cells
from I4 to T25.
Okay, so we've got the chart in the right
place now, and we've sized it how we like.
Next, what we want to do is plot some data
within it.
And to do this, you can right-click within
the chart and go to select data, and then
choose to add a series.
And the next dialog box asks us to enter
the name of the data series, which we'll
just put as adjusted close or ADJ space
close.
And then we need to select the series
values as well.
So when we click into the series values
box, you'll need to delete whatever is
already there and type over it with a
range of cells that covers all of the
adjusted close prices for this stock.
Now, normally at this stage, it would be
common to select cell F2, for example,
which is the first closing price that we
have in the series, and then press
Ctrl-Shift and down on the keyboard to
select all of the cells within that column
to the bottom of the data series.
And when I do that, you can see that it
populates the series values box
appropriately.
However, in this example, we want to make
sure that this chart automatically updates
whenever we add in new data.
So it's kind of future-proof.
So it needs to be able to reference cells
many rows beyond whatever the current
final row is in the data set.
So what I'm going to do here is instead
change the array reference that we've got
to F2 to something like F100,000.
So we've got many more rows and more than
enough room for the data set to expand if
we want to update it for the foreseeable
future.
So that's just a nice little trick to kind
of future-proof your chart so you don't
need to keep updating the range reference
as you add more data.
So with the closing price data added to
the chart, what we now need to do is make
sure we apply the labels that we want to
the horizontal axis.
And the labels that we're going to use are
just going to be our dates.
So we can do that by clicking on the Edit
Horizontal Axis Labels button and then
filling in the cell range for our dates.
And we'll do this in exactly the same way
as I did previously for adding a series.
So if I scroll back to the top of the
sheet and then select cell A2, press
Ctrl-Shift and down on the keyboard to get
to the end of the data series.
Again, this time we do need to make sure
that we create an array that is a lot
longer than our current data set.
Again, so we're future-proofing.
And actually this needs to be exactly the
same length as the closing prices array
that we just used.
So I'm just going to write over this last
row here, one, nine, four, five, with
100,000.
So we're going from A2 to A100,000.
All right, the chart's looking okay as it
is now.
But what I want to do is quickly show you
a few small aesthetic changes that you can
make to make it look a little bit neater.
And the first one is just a neat little
trick to create a dynamic title for the
chart.
And you can do that just by left-clicking
and selecting the title element of the
chart.
And then in the formula bar, type in an
equal sign followed by selecting a cell
reference.
So this will basically result in the chart
title being equal to whatever is entered
into that cell reference that was picked.
So in this example, I'm just going to type
into the formula bar an equal sign.
And then I'm going to select the cell J2
and press enter.
So basically, whatever we see now as the
company name will be reflected in the
chart title.
And that will update automatically if we
were to change whatever the value is or
the company name is in cell J2.
Another little hack to make the chart
dates a little bit easier to read is to
rotate them 45 degrees and to choose some
custom intervals.
So for this example, if I right-click the
date axis here and choose format axis, I
can change the major units to something
more suitable.
So maybe six months in this case.
And then next, to rotate the dates
themselves, you can just left-click the
date axis again and go to home on the
ribbon.
And choose angle counterclockwise from the
text orientation button.
And then finally, the last change I want
to make here is to the data line itself.
And to make changes to that line, you just
need to double-click the chart line itself
and navigate to the fill and line tab that
you'll see from the formatting panel
that's appeared on the right-hand side.
And within that tab, you can change all
sorts of style options.
In this case, all I'm going to do is make
some simple changes.
I'm just going to make the line black and
the width of that line a little bit
smaller.
So just to 1pt.
Okay, so that's all there is to it in
terms of making a simple price chart from
some imported data in Excel.
And by the way, when you guys do this
yourselves, a quick tip that I have to
speed things up for you is just to copy
one of your existing stock sheets in this
file already.
And just replace the data that you see in
columns A to G with some newly downloaded
data.
That way, you're not going to need to go
through the whole process of building the
chart every time.
All you need to do is rename the sheet and
also the cells containing the ticker and
the company name, which of course will
then be reflected in the chart titles as
well.
Okay, so as I said earlier, I will show
you now how to plot some moving averages
and trend lines on price charts.
So let's go through that plotting and
moving average is very simple.
Basically, Excel already has this
functionality built in.
All you need to do is select the chart
line and then click on design in the
ribbon, followed by add chart element, and
then choose moving average from the trend
line options that you see in that drop
down.
With that done, you can then go to format
on the ribbon and select the trend line
element.
that you just created in the top left drop
down and click format selection.
And then what you're going to see is
basically a format trend line panel appear
on the right hand side here at the
worksheet.
And from there, you can change the line
color and style.
And importantly, if you select the trend
line options tab, you can change the
number of periods the moving average is
determined by.
So for this example, we're looking at
daily data.
If we want to create a three month moving
average, we'd enter 60 into the period box
because using daily data here, there are
20 periods or 20 trading days in each
month.
So a three month moving average would be
60 periods.
If you want to draw on trend lines or
things like support and resistance, you
can also do that quite easily.
First, you need to make sure that you've
selected the plot area by left clicking
it.
And then to draw shapes within that plot
area, you simply go to the insert tab on
the ribbon and choose whichever shape you
want.
So for example, a line, you can then draw
that line by left clicking and dragging
your cursor to create starting and ending
points of the line.
And by doing it in this way, what we're
making sure of is that the lines and the
shapes that you draw will move around with
the chart area.
So that's why we selected the plot area
first.
However, when you do update the chart with
more data, you will probably need to make
some edits to the lines that you draw to
maintain their accuracy,
and which you can do easily by clicking
and dragging the nodes at each end of the
line.
Once it's selected, sometimes it's useful
as well to have various timeframes charted
for a particular asset or economic
indicator,
whatever data you're looking at, rather
than looking at the entire historical data
set.
And an easy way that I kind of do this is
just to copy a chart that you've already
made like this one here and then edit the
date axis
and the value axis is desired.
So for example, if we want to create a
chart that just looks at the data from
2019 onwards,
we can just select the chart that we
already have and then copy and paste it
with either the right click functions I
showed earlier,
or as I tend to use just the keyboard
shortcuts.
So copy with control C, followed by
control V to paste it once that new
charts, then here as it is now, you can
sort of size it, position it how you want.
And you can double click the date axis to
format it and change the minimum date as
we're going to do in this example to 2019.
Obviously, you can put that to any date
you wish, so long as you've got the data
for that date, it's probably also a good
idea in this example,
to change or reset the intervals, because
the previous intervals that we use were
for a lot longer data set and they're not
really sort of relevant or they don't
really work that well for a much smaller
data set.
So from prices just from 2019 onwards, so
we can make them more relevant just by it,
by changing that quickly now.
So I think one month will do.
And you can also change the scaling for
the value axis at the moment.
You can see the price values go all the
way up to $120 a share because that's the
automatic maximum based on the entire data
data series we have available.
However, you can manually override that if
you want to make the window of data we're
looking at a little bit clearer.
And to do that, you just double click on
the value axis and you can choose the
values maximum and minimum values that you
can see here just by overwriting the
values that you see in the boxes.
So for the maximum, we might change it
from 120 in this example to 30.
You can also, as I said, change the
minimum here, which might be suitable for
stocks with a much higher share price,
just to sort of get the scaling right.
So you can see the changes in price more
easily over time.
You'll notice that the trend line that's
being copied across from the first chart
to the second chart has not adjusted to
the changes that we've made when we've
changed the sort of window of data that
we're looking at.
And, you know, scaled both axes.
So that needs to be edited, as I said
earlier, and you can do that really easily
just by selecting the line and clicking
and dragging the nodes at each end to the
desired locations.
Okay, so hopefully, all of that formatting
stuff makes sense and was easy enough to
follow.
The final thing that I want to know about
these stock sheets is that in order to
update them, all you need to do is copy
and paste some new price data over the old
data, as long as it's from the same source
and in the same format.
So, you know, in this case, from Yahoo
Finance.
So let's take an example.
If we consider a scenario where we hadn't
updated this price data since the end of
2020 and so we want to update it with all
of the new 2021 data, then we would start
by, I'll sort of simulate this.
So I'll start by deleting all of the post
2021 data.
So we're imagining now we've only got data
up to the end of 2020.
And assuming we're in this position and we
want to update this stock for all of the
2021 data, all you'd need to do is
download the data from the same source in
the same format and copy those columns of
data into this sheet.
So columns A to G in this case, that would
mean downloading and updating the data
from Yahoo Finance.
As I said, copying columns A to G over
just as we did earlier.
And so I'll just do that quickly.
Now, if we go back to the FireEye data
sheet that we downloaded from Yahoo
Finance earlier and carry out that process
here, I'm just copying columns A to G and
pasting them into the FireEye sheet in
this portfolio modeling sheet.
And you can see now that all the charts
and everything is updated to reflect that
new data.
And that's all there is to it, really.
That's also, you know, the main reason why
we made sure that when we entered the cell
ranges for our data series in the charts
and our date series as well, we made sure
that they would encompass data a lot
further down the sheet than our initial
data set.
So remember, we chose down to row 100,000
that so that it can make sure it updates
with new data like we've just kind of
proven here.
So that's it for the first section of the
video.
And you now know how to download and plot
stock price data in Excel.
All fairly straightforward so far, but it
is useful stuff.
And everything we go through is just going
to act as building blocks as you learn
more and more through the course.
Let's move on to the next section now,
which is where we're going to look at how
to compare the performance of two stocks
in the form of a spread trade.
And what I mean by that is a pairs trade
where we're looking at going long one
stock versus short another, the same
principles that we're going to cover here
can be applied across other assets as
well, if that's something that you wish to
do.
So when we look at one stock, it's fairly
obvious how to assess its performance and
all you need to do really is look at its
price or total returns over time.
However, if you're looking at two stocks
in the form of a long and a short
position, we need to find a way of
combining their individual performance
into a single data series.
And what we're going to look at in this
section are various different methods of
doing that using fresh pair and dollar
tree stocks as examples.
The first couple of methods I want to show
you are quite crude, but easy to carry
out.
And then I'm going to go through what are
essentially a couple more accurate
approaches which can be carried forward to
analyzing performance at the portfolio
level with more than two stocks.
And that's something that we're going to
be doing later in the video.
So the first two calculations I'm going to
use here are what's called the spread and
ratio methods.
And as always, the first step here is to
obtain the data that we need.
In this case, we need the price series
data for fresh pair and dollar tree, and
we need to create a common time series for
both of them.
That basically means that we need to make
sure that we only use price data when it's
available to both stocks on any given day.
So let's start by copying and pasting the
price and date series for each stock into
this blank sheet here, spread and ratio
analysis from the relevant individual
stock tabs.
So starting with fresh pair, the ticker is
FRPT.
So we can navigate to that sheet.
And all we need to do here is select both
the date and the adjusted close columns by
holding down control on the keyboard and
left clicking on those columns.
And with them both selected, I'm just
going to copy them with control C and then
paste them into control V into columns A
and B of the spread and ratio analysis
sheet.
Similarly, for dollar tree now, that's
DLTR, the ticker.
So we can go to the DLTR sheet and we can
do the same thing.
And I'll copy those columns into columns E
and F of the spread and ratio analysis
sheet.
Before we go any further, let's rename the
columns B and F to reflect the tickers for
those two stocks.
So in cell B2, I'm just going to type FRPT
for fresh pet and in cell F2, I'm going to
type DLTR for dollar tree.
Now, if we look at the time series here,
we can see quite clearly that the data
series that we have for dollar tree goes
back to 1995,
whilst the series for fresh pet is a lot
shorter since the dates only go back to
2014.
To compare these two stocks fairly, we
need to only use price data on dates that
are shared by both assets,
which basically means we can only use
price data corresponding to the shorter
time series.
To make sure that we're matching price
data from the dollar tree series with the
dates that we see in the fresh pet series,
we can use an Excel lookup function called
VLOOKUP.
So in cell C2 here, I'm going to type
equals VLOOKUP.
That's our function.
Then open brackets because we always need
to fill out the parameters for our
function and you put those in brackets.
And we've got four parameters to fill in
here.
The first is choosing the date that we
want to look up.
That's going to be cell A2.
Then I'm going to put in a comma and
choose columns E to F,
which is the data table that we're going
to look within.
And then I'm going to put another comma
and put in two,
because we're going to look in the second
column of that data table.
And then finally another comma followed by
FALSE, which is just a parameter that
makes sure we look up the correct date.
So let me explain what this does a little
bit more clearly.
So the function performs a vertical lookup
of the value that we see in cell A2,
which is our date from the fresh pet
series.
And it looks it up in the table array of
columns E to F, which is our dollar tree
data.
It then returns the value in the second
column of that array that we specified.
And the FALSE parameter at the end of the
function just makes sure that it only
returns an exact match
for the date that we're looking up.
So again, just to be clear, the function
is looking up a date from the fresh pet
series column B.
It's finding it in the dollar tree series
column E.
It then returns the corresponding price
from the dollar tree series in column F.
And this function basically just makes
sure that we're lining up prices of the
two stocks correctly.
So with that function inputted,
we can just copy it down to find all the
dollar tree prices on those particular
dates.
So now we know that our prices are aligned
properly.
Let's tidy things up a little bit.
We want to be able to delete the dollar
tree data series in columns E to F.
Now, since we've aligned those prices
properly in column C.
However, if we delete columns E to F, then
the formulas that we've created in column
C
will return errors because they can no
longer look up prices from the deleted
columns.
So to get around this problem, all we need
to do is convert the formulas in column C
to their hard outputs or values.
And the easiest way to do this is by
copying the column and pasting the values
over themselves,
but as values instead of the formulas.
To do that, just copy column C and then
right click within that selection
and select the paste as values clipboard
option from the dropdown menu.
And you can see now if I click on one of
the cells that previously had our lookup
formulas in
that we specified earlier, it now just has
the output values of those formulas.
So with that done, we can safely delete
columns E to F now by selecting them,
right clicking within the selection and
choosing delete.
Don't forget as well to give column C a
title, which is for this example,
it can just be DLTR, the ticker for dollar
tree.
Now we've got our price data ready for
both stocks.
Let's talk about what spread and ratio
calculation methods actually are.
A spread is just the price difference
between two assets, meaning for example,
subtracting the price of dollar tree from
fresh pet.
And a ratio is the price of one asset
divided by another.
So for example, the price of fresh pet
divided by the price of dollar tree.
Both of these methods are simple ways to
create a common time series that you can
use to track the performance of trading a
long short pair.
As a side note though, when you're
comparing a long idea versus a short idea
by using a spread or
ratio index, the convention is always to
have your long idea as the first variable
in the equation,
meaning for a spread calculation, you take
the long price minus the short price.
And for a ratio calculation, you take the
long price divided by the short price.
So let's calculate the spread and ratio
time series for these stocks now,
based on the assumption that our long idea
is fresh pet and our short idea is dollar
tree.
In column D, I'm going to calculate the
spread and in cell D1,
I'm just going to head the column with
FRPT minus DLTR.
Below that heading in cell D2, we need to
write in a formula as follows.
And that's just going to be equals and
then the cell reference B2 minus C2.
So you can just type in equals and then
select B2, then hit minus on the keyboard
and select cell C2.
That's just the price of fresh pet on the
date in row two.
So the 7th of November, 2014 minus the
price of dollar tree on that same date.
And when we copy this formula down by
double clicking the little green box in
the bottom right of the cell selection,
that'll copy down that formula for the
relevant dates all the way down to the end
of the data series.
Once you do that, always make sure when
you copy a formula down or across a sheet
that you check the data afterwards.
And the easiest way to do that is to
navigate to the end of the series where
you've copied down or across.
And here I'm just doing that by pressing
control and down on the keyboard to
quickly get to the end of the data series.
And then double click on the final
calculation cell and just make sure that
you're happy with the references and how
the formula is working.
Now let's move on to ratio calculations
then.
In cell E1, I'm going to title the column
FRPT forward slash, so divided by DLTR.
And in the cell below, the formula this
time is going to be equals B2 divided by
C2.
And as before, we need to copy down that
formula to the end of the series and check
it as well as we did for column D.
And you can see here that all the
calculations look correct.
They've yielded values to multiple decimal
places, so the formatting is a little
untidy.
What we can do is just format that column
of data by selecting column E and
right-clicking within the selection and
then going to format cells.
Choosing the number option and then
formatting the numbers to three decimal
places.
Okay, great.
We've now got the underlying data sorted,
but before I move on to explaining how and
when spread and ratio calculations are
useful,
we need to create some charts to
illustrate the new data series that we've
calculated.
Now we've already been through the
charting process, so I'll make this one
quite quick.
I want to create a line chart to plot the
spread series first.
And so I'm just going to select insert on
the ribbon, followed by 2D line chart.
And from there, I'll move and resize the
chart and then right-click within the
chart area and go to select data.
Within that dialog box, I'm now going to
choose to add a new series and then select
the series name as cell D1
and the series values as the entire series
we calculated in column D.
So that would be all the data from cell D2
down to the end of the data series.
Now, I know in the previous example, we
extended this to blank rows well beyond
the data series.
Obviously, you can do that if you think
you're going to continuously update this
chart with new data.
In this case, I don't think that's
particularly relevant, so I'm just going
to leave it there at the end of the data
set.
So next, what you want to do is add our
horizontal axis labels, which we can do
again from inside the select data source
dialog box.
And to do that, you click on the edit
horizontal axis button and then choose the
corresponding dates for all the spread
series data.
So in this case, that's going to be all
the dates from cell A2 down to the end of
the data series again.
And that's all there is to selecting data
sources for our chart.
So you can click OK to come out of those
options now and we can see the chart
there.
And we're basically done now aside from
any formatting changes that you might want
to do.
And I'm not going to go through what I've
already talked about in terms of
formatting.
But one thing that I do want to add here
is that for charts that display negative
data, as this one does,
I do think it looks better if you move the
date axis labels to the bottom of the
chart rather than on the zero axis.
And to do that, you just need to double
click the date labels, which should open a
format axis panel on the right hand side.
And then from there, you can go to labels
and choose the label position as low from
the drop down menu.
So that's the spread chart done.
Let's move on to the ratio chart now.
The process here is exactly the same.
I'm going to start by inserting a 2D line
chart and then resizing the chart area to
something similar to the chart that we
just made.
And after that, again, we need to add data
sources to the chart.
So I'll right click within the chart area
and go to select data and add data series.
Then I'm going to choose cell E1 this time
as the series name.
And for the series values, we're going to
select cell E2 to the end of the series.
And just to add the dates as well to this
series, we can come out of that and then
click edit
horizontal axis labels and select cell A2
to the end of the series to add our dates.
Okay, now we've run the calculations and
created charts for our new series.
Let's talk about how and when the spread
and ratio calculations can be useful.
If we take a look at the spread first
between the two stocks, as I said
previously, this is just the
difference between the price per share of
the two stocks.
So essentially what the data shows is the
performance of going long one share of
fresh pet and short one share of dollar
tree.
Now, obviously, this can be extrapolated
as well to two or three or any number of
shares,
as long as they're equal on both the long
and short side.
So let's take an example now.
In July 2020, the spread between these
stocks was roughly zero,
meaning that one share for each company
cost around the same price.
But by February 2021, fresh pet cost
around $60 more than DLTR than dollar
tree,
which tells us that if you were long one
share of fresh pet and short one share of
dollar tree,
you would have made about $60 over the
period.
Not including, of course, any fees that
you would pay along the way, trading costs
and things like that.
So equally as well, if you were to go long
and short two shares of fresh pet and
dollar tree,
respectively, you would have made $120,
which is, of course, $60 times by two.
So that's what spread performance does.
It shows us the performance in dollar per
share terms of one stock versus another,
provided that there's an equal number of
shares applied to both assets.
The ratio calculation is a bit different.
In this case, mathematically, what you're
calculating is the price of the long stock
as a percentage of the price of the short
stock.
And this method is regularly used in
finance as a measure of out or under
performance between one
asset and another based on both stocks
being equally weighted in dollar terms.
So not in share terms in the actual dollar
capital committed to each side of the
trade.
Unfortunately, it is also sometimes
mistakenly used as an exact measure of the
constant equal
weighted performance you would achieve if
you were to implement a long short pairs
trade like this.
I'm going to talk a bit more about that
later.
But equally weighted just means that the
same amount of dollars are committed to
each side of the trade
and constant in this case just means that
the weighting doesn't change over time.
And I say mistakenly used because whilst a
ratio calculation does offer a very good
indication
of the directional performance of the
trade, you can't estimate your percentage
returns from it.
And if you did, they would end up being
grossly exaggerated one way or the other.
However, that being said, the ratio method
does have a very high correlation
to more accurate measures of equal
weighting or equally weighted performance.
And that is why, as I said before, it is
often used as a quick way to gauge
whether one stock is outperforming another
or not.
So, for example, the way you might use a
ratio is if we look at the ratio chart
here
for fresh pet versus dollar tree, whenever
the line is going up,
we know that our long, so fresh pet in
this case, is outperforming our short and
vice versa.
And that's really mostly what a ratio is
actually good for.
You cannot use the ratio as a way of
calculating the percentage change or the
percentage returns that
you would achieve.
So basically, you can't use the ratio to
measure the percentage change of the ratio
and equate that to the percentage returns
you would see if you put on those two
positions.
If you want to be able to precisely assess
the historical performance of a long
position versus
a short position, then probably the
fairest way to do so is to work out the
percentage returns for
each position over every period and then
apply equal weightings to the long and
short sides before
then, of course, combining them into an
overall return.
In our data set, we're looking at daily
intervals.
So what that means is that for every
trading day, we want to calculate the
daily percentage
return for each stock.
And once we've done that, all we do is
create an overall return for each period
by summing the
equally weighted returns of both the long
and short positions.
This methodology that I'm talking about is
sometimes referred to as a constant
equally weighted
approach because for every calculation
date, the returns for each position are
equally weighted,
which means that on every day, we're
assuming that an equal amount of capital
in dollar terms is
committed to each position.
Now, practically speaking, this isn't very
reasonable since whenever stock prices
move,
the weightings will become imbalanced.
And so realistically, you would need to
rebalance the weightings every day to
implement this properly.
However, it does mean that when looking at
a time series of performance,
the two positions are always fairly
assessed in terms of their relative
performance.
So let's go ahead and do this analysis for
our long FRPT and short DLTR trade so that
we can compare
our results to the work that we've already
done with the spread and ratio analysis.
So to start with, in the performance CEW
sheet, I'm going to copy over the price
data that we used
in the spread and ratio analysis sheet
just by selecting the right columns and
copying them across.
From there, I want to basically calculate
the daily returns for each of these stocks
across the entire
time series.
So starting with Fresh Pet, in column D,
I'm going to title the column FRPT
percent.
And in cell D3, I'm going to type in a
formula which is equals cell B3 divided by
cell B2 minus 1.
This formula basically calculates the
percentage change in price from cell B2 to
B3.
So that's the closing price on the 7th of
November to the closing price on the 10th
of November.
And you might have noticed there that
those dates aren't sequential, okay?
Not sequential calendar dates anyway, but
they are sequential trading days because
those dates are over a weekend.
Now, one thing to note here is that our
data is arranged in ascending order.
So what that means is that the oldest data
is at the top of the sheet
and the most recent data is at the bottom
of the sheet.
And so the first formula that we've put in
is in cell D3, not D2.
And that's because to calculate the
percentage returns for each day or for
each period,
we need the data from the prior period,
which wouldn't have existed if we started
in the top row.
So with this formula in place, we can copy
it down as we've done many times before,
and then double check that the formula
looks good at the end of the series, which
you can see it does.
So let's now go through the same process
for dollar tree returns,
except we don't need to retype the formula
in here.
And instead, what we can do is just copy
across the formula that we've got in cell
D3 to cell E3.
And to do this, you just click and select
cell D3 and then drag the little green
mark in the bottom
right of that cell selection across to the
new cell E3.
Just in the same way as we might have done
if we copied down, you can also copy
across in this way.
So if we then double click in the formula
just to check it, you can see that the
cell references
have moved appropriately by one column to
reference the dollar tree prices instead
of fresh pet prices,
so we can feel confident with that
formula. And with that done, again, we can
copy the formula
down to the end of the data series just by
double clicking the little green box in
the bottom right
of the cell selection. And before I go any
further, let's just format these columns
of returns to
display themselves as percentages, because
actually, at the moment, they're a bit
hard to read just as
decimals. So we can do that just by
selecting the columns, right clicking
within the selection and
choosing format cells. And then we select
the percentage option. And for this
example, we'll round the
percentages to two decimal places. Now, as
I said earlier, we need to combine these
two sets of
returns into an overall return that
measures the performance of our long
versus our short, which
I'm going to do in column F. To begin
with, I'm going to title the column CEW
percent, meaning
constant equal weighting percentage. The
overall percentage returns for this
portfolio of two stocks is
easy to calculate. All we need to do is
apply an equal weight to the long and
short returns and add them
together. So there's two things we need to
do here. First, at the moment, we've
calculated the returns for
both the stocks we're looking at as if
they're long positions. And remember,
we're assuming we're long,
fresh pet, but short dollar tree in this
example. And so when we combine the
returns, we need to make
sure that we invert the dollar tree
returns and make them negative so that
they equate to being short
dollar tree. Second, if we're going to
equal weight the two positions, we need to
make sure that we apply
a 50% weighting to each set of returns,
which would then together equate to 100%
for the spread trade
as a whole. As I said before, this sort of
constant equal weighting approach is the
fairest way to
calculate relative performance between the
two assets, but it isn't always the most
realistic option.
And I'm going to touch on that a bit more
later. So anyway, in cell F3, the formula
for our combined
returns is just going to be 0.5 times by
cell D3, close brackets, and then adding
in brackets 0.5 times
minus cell E3, close brackets. And if we
look at this formula more closely, all
we're doing here is
basically adding together two components,
a 50% weighting to the long fresh pet
returns and a 50%
weighting to the short dollar tree
returns. And the reason why we have a
negative sign before
referencing the dollar tree returns is to
transform those returns to represent a
short position in the
stock. So that effectively gives us our
returns for the combination of the two
positions. And as you
guys are going to see shortly, this is
pretty much identical to the approach that
we're going to take
to calculating constant equal weighted
portfolio returns later in the video. The
difference being
here is that this is just an example of a
portfolio of just two positions instead of
many, as we're
going to see later. Okay, let's move on.
If you want to chart the performance of
this long short pair,
we need to create an index, which is
another useful skill actually when it
comes to doing your own
trading analyses in general. So in cell
G1, I'm going to title the column CEW
index. And below that
in cell G2, we can start the index at any
value we wish. And common practice is to
start indices from
a value of 100. So that's the value that
I'm going to enter into cell G2 here. And
that's going to
represent the index value of this mini
portfolio on the 7th of November. Now in
cell G3, to calculate
the index value on the 10th of November,
all we need to do is multiply the previous
index value, so 100,
by 1 plus the returns for that period. So
what that's going to mean is in cell G3,
I'm going to type in the
formula, equals cell G2, multiplied by, in
brackets, 1 plus cell F3. And so that's
just going to be the
previous index value G2, multiplied by 1
plus the portfolio returns, or the
combined returns for the
two positions, given that they're equally
weighted. So as we've done previously, we
can copy this formula
down as well and format it appropriately.
I'm going to format the column this time
by selecting column G
and going to home on the ribbon, just to
show you a different way to achieve the
same sort of thing.
And I'm going to choose to format the
values as numbers to two decimal places in
this case.
So that's just a different way of
formatting something rather than right
clicking in the selection
and going to format cells. Finally, with
this performance index calculated, we can
chart it.
And as before, I'm just going to insert a
2D line chart quickly, reposition it and
size it to
sort of this kind of size, and then select
the appropriate data sources by right
clicking in the
chart area and going to select data
sources. The data series that we need to
add is the CEW index,
with the title of the series set to cell
G1 and the data value selected as cell G2
down to the end of
the series. And after that, of course, we
need to make sure to add our horizontal
axis labels as well,
which are determined by the corresponding
dates to those values for the index that
we've just created.
So the dates will just be, the date
reference will just be from cell A2
downwards, and then we can
press OK twice to view the chart. Okay,
let's have a quick recap here. What we've
just done is basically
calculate or create a constantly equally
weighted index of performance, which has
been based at a value of
100 on the 7th of November, 2014. The
index is made up from the combined
performance of two individual
positions, long fresh pet and short dollar
tree. And to get to this point, we needed
to calculate
the returns for each of those assets over
every period in our time series, and then
combine them
by applying a 50% weighting to the long
FRPT returns and a 50% weighting to the
short DLTR returns. And then
we added those together. Now I'm going to
come back to how this way of measuring
performance differs to
those we've covered previously in a
minute. But first, what I want to address
is something I said
earlier about this being a fair way to
calculate the out or under performance of
two stocks, but it not
necessarily being the most practical
method. It's fair because an equal weight
is assigned to both the
returns of the long position and the short
position for the entire duration of the
data set. So whenever
the portfolio goes up, we can guarantee
that it's because the long idea has
outperformed the short
idea and vice versa. As far as overall
returns go, it's also very accurate, so
long as the assumptions of
constant and equal weighting hold true.
However, from a practical perspective,
this is very difficult to
implement, especially using such small
daily intervals as we've done here. The
reason being is
that in order to maintain an equal weight
in both positions for each period, you
would need to,
in practice, rebalance at the beginning of
every period to make sure exactly the same
amount of
capital is committed to each trade. So
think about it this way, if you were to
buy 10 shares of Fresh
Pet on the 10th of June 2021 at $168 a
share, you will have committed $1,680 to
that position. And let's
just say for argument's sake that you
could short exactly the same dollar amount
of Dollar Tree on the
same day. If the price of Dollar Tree
didn't move, but Fresh Pet went up 10%
after you bought them that day,
then at the open on the next trading day,
you'll have $1,848 in Fresh Pet and only
$1,680 shorting
Dollar Tree because the Dollar Tree price
didn't move, but the Fresh Pet price went
up 10%. That means
that you no longer have an equal weighting
in both assets unless you go about
rebalancing those positions.
So you can see why that's quite
impractical. It might be okay to do on a
monthly or quarterly basis,
but it's pretty impractical to do on a
daily basis and obviously the costs
incurred in constantly
rebalancing like that would be high. So
although the equally weighted measure of
outperformance is
the fairest from an objective point of
view, it might not be the most practical.
So what I want to do now
is show you how you calculate the non
rebalanced performance for the same
portfolio. And then
finally, I'm going to wrap things up with
all of the measures that we've looked at
so far and compare
the performance of each of them.
In this next sheet, we're looking at non
rebalanced performance of the same two
stocks. And as you can
see, it's already pre-assembled. So I'm
just going to talk through the steps that
it took to create it.
And then you guys can always backward
engineer them if you wish to do so. I'm
then going to conclude
with just a few points about the benefits
and drawbacks regarding non rebalanced
performance
measurement. So building this sheet
requires very similar methods to those
which we've already
used up to this point in the video. We
start with our FRPT and DLTR prices,
and then we calculate returns. From there,
I've created two indices, one for each
stock,
starting from values of 50. And I chose
those values so that it's easy to
visualize both stocks
having 50% weightings at the beginning of
the data series back in 2014. And also
when you add them
together, it will create an index value
for 100 to base from. The indices for each
stock are created
by sequentially multiplying the index
values by 1 plus the stock returns for
each period.
There's no adjustment for shorting at this
stage. We account for that in the next
formula,
in the next column, which is the overall
non rebalanced performance index.
In this column, the index is based by
summing the starting values of the two
stocks,
the two stock indices, as I said. And by
the way, you can actually change these two
values to whatever you
like since they essentially mimic the
gross exposure to each position. But as I
said,
for the purposes of this example, I want
to keep them equally weighted, each with
an index base of 50.
So after the overall index base is defined
by summing the two stock index bases, the
subsequent
index values are calculated by adding the
change in the long index and subtracting
the change in the
short index to the prior overall index
value. For example, in cell H8 here, the
formula takes
the previous value of the overall index,
adds the change in the FRPT index and
subtracts the change in
the DLTR index. And that's because our
dollar tree position is a short. And so
that's where we make our
adjustment. Note that by calculating
performance this way, we're not equally
weighting the returns in every
period as we did before, but are instead
effectively implementing a buy and hold
strategy for FRPT and
a short and hold strategy for DLTR,
starting with obviously the same amount of
capital to each trade.
And as you would expect, because of that,
the weightings in the non-rebalanced index
change
dramatically over time. And I've
calculated how those weightings change in
columns J and K for you
guys to have a look at. If we have a look
at the charts here, you'll notice that the
non-rebalanced
index performance is quite different to
the constant equal weighted performance,
the CEW performance
index that we looked at previously. And as
you would expect, performance starts off
looking quite
similar when the weightings are roughly
equal, but as they drift further and
further apart, so does the
correlation to the prior index we
calculated. So as the weightings drift
apart, so does the correlation
to the prior index that we calculated. And
you guys are going to be able to see this
a little bit better
in the next comparison sheet that we're
going to look at shortly. I've also
created another chart here
to show you just how much the weightings
do change over the period that we're
looking at.
The blue filled portion of the chart
represents the fresh pet weighting, and
the orange fill represents the
dollar tree weighting in the index. You
can see that in November 2014, they both
make up about 50% of the
index or exactly 50% of the index. And
then the weighting to dollar tree
increases at one point to
as high as 80% in late 2015, early 2016.
And then the FRPT weighting increased from
then onwards to the
point where it counts for almost 85% of
the index by June 2021. There is another
point that I want to
make about weightings now, which will be
useful for you guys to understand when
you're managing your own
portfolios. And that is basically that for
your long positions that you have in your
portfolios,
the weightings for those positions will
increase as the underlying stock performs
favorably, and
therefore the position performs favorably.
So the stock price is going up. But for
short positions,
weightings will also increase as the stock
price goes up, which means that the
weightings increase
as effectively you're losing money in your
position rather than gaining money. And
that's just a good
thing to have in the back of your mind,
just for sort of how the weightings in
your portfolio will change
as prices move in your longs and shorts.
So this non-rebalanced performance that
we're looking at
here is useful to us because it tells us
the actual gross returns before any fees
or anything like that
we would have achieved given holding these
positions for a certain length of time and
with
the starting weightings that we've
applied. So for example, with this
portfolio where we're long FRPT,
short DLTR, you would have made close to
350% from November, 2014 to June, 2021,
since the portfolio
index starts here around a hundred and
finishes in June, 2021, around a value of
450. In reality,
a trade is never going to last that long.
And if it did, the financing fees, of
course,
for the shorts and leveraged positions
would be quite significant if you were
leveraged.
The point of using a long data set like
this, as we've done here though, is so
that we can compare
it to the previous equally weighted
performance calculation that we ran. And
you can see how
significant the weighting drift can be
over time. So what are the positives and
negatives of measuring
non-rebalanced performance in this way?
Well, as I said previously, the
methodology might be a bit more
realistic to the performance that you want
to measure. It's going to answer questions
such as
if I traded the same amount of dollars in
each of these stocks at a certain time,
what would my
performance have been over the period
given no further trading? It effectively
calculates your
holding period return and your index
profit and loss curve along the way for a
mini portfolio of two
positions, one long and one short. And by
the way, if you guys want to experiment,
see what would happen
with different dollar weightings, you
could just overwrite these cells here, F8
and G8 with whatever
values that you want. So for example, you
could model how the trade would have
performed if you committed
$1,000 to the long side and $2,000 to the
short side. And when we enter those
values, you can see here
that all the charts and stuff updates. And
you could, of course, specifically model a
certain number of
shares in each position as well, just by
making the starting values some multiple
of the initial prices
for each stock. So that is all fairly
simple to do. And you guys can play around
with that as much as you
want. So despite this method being perhaps
a more realistic measure of performance,
if you're just
trying to keep an eye out on the
outperformance of one stock versus
another, then equally weighted
performance calculations are going to work
better. Because that way you can look at a
chart and if the
index value is increasing at any point in
time, you know you're long outperformed,
you're short at that
time and vice versa. That is actually not
true and not the case in the
non-rebalanced index. So with a
non-rebalanced index, all you can say for
sure is that one stock outperformed the
other over the entire
length of the series, but not for any
specific window within it, because the
weightings might not
be 50-50 at that point that you're looking
at. So for example, if I change the values
back to 50-50
here and you look at the weightings when
the index comes to an end, you can see
that FRPT has a rough
weight of about 85% in the index to DLTR's
15%. So that would mean if the price of
Dollar Tree fell 50%,
which remember would be a 50% gain in our
short position and beneficial to our
portfolio,
the price of Fresh Pet would have only had
to decrease by about 9% for the net effect
to be
negative on the overall index. So if the
overall return was negative, then in an
equal weighted
portfolio we would know that Dollar Tree
outperformed Fresh Pet over the period.
But because the weightings
are so different in the example I just
gave, the opposite was actually true.
Fresh Pet outperformed
Dollar Tree because it only decreased 9%
compared to Dollar Tree decreasing 50%.
That is why looking at
non-rebalanced performance doesn't
actually reflect outperformance in your
long versus your short over
every time window that you can look at,
just over the entire length of the series.
Whenever the weightings
in a long short index like this are
unequal, you can never be sure which stock
is actually outperforming the
other just by looking at the movements in
the overall index level. So to conclude,
non-rebalanced indexing
is great for calculating holding period
returns and modelling historical trading
scenarios as we've kind
of done here. But constant equal weighting
performance is better for understanding
whether one stock has
been outperforming another at any point in
time. I hope that all makes sense. Now
before I go on to
portfolio calculations, I want to briefly
show you the difference in the various
methodologies that
I've used so far for measuring out or
under performance between two stocks. I'm
not going
to do a whole lot of talking here, instead
I'm just going to point you to this chart
here to reassure
you that basically what I've been saying
isn't nonsense and these different methods
do actually yield
different results. So in the chart you can
see the quick and dirty ratio method that
we looked at first,
as well as the constant equal weighting
and non-rebalanced index methods. I've
already discussed
how those two are different, why the
constant and equal weighted method and
non-rebalanced methods are
different. One thing I want to quickly add
to that is proof of something that I
mentioned earlier,
which is that the ratio index is also
different to the constant equal weighted
approach. And as I said
previously, that is something that's often
misunderstood. That being said though, the
major inaccuracy really in
performance measurement here is just a
scaling problem. And the ratio index is
actually quite
tightly correlated to the CEW index. And
in fact, the two indices are kind of over
95% correlated on the
whole. Despite when you look at the
performance over the time period that
we've analyzed here, the ratio index
ends up being about 130% higher than the
constant equal weighted performance index.
So the conclusion here is that different
measures of performance will affect the
overall returns that
you calculate. And if you want to follow
sort of mathematically rigorous methods,
you need to be
using either the non-rebalanced or the
constant weighting approaches that I've
mentioned. And just be
sure to understand what they represent and
their applications before you use them. If
you want
to calculate dollar performance quickly on
an equal share basis, then the spread
method that we looked
at at the beginning is also okay, but it's
not great at measuring out or under
performance on a percentage
basis because the weightings are
inherently different due to the
differences in share prices.
If you want to be able to quickly glance
at a chart and understand whether one
stock has outperformed
another, then the ratio method is also
okay. Just don't go assuming that you can
go any further
than that and start calculating returns.
Okay. I'm done talking about measuring
performance differences
and combined performance of two stocks.
There was quite a lot of detail in there
in that section,
but it was necessary to go through those
building blocks so that what I talk about
next makes more
sense. And what we're going to look at now
is how to model historical portfolio
performance. And to do
that, we need to be able to calculate
portfolio returns, which is done simply by
adding up all the weighted
returns of the positions inside the
portfolio. So for example, if you had a
portfolio of two long
stock positions with the same capital
commitment to each and one made 5% whilst
the other made 10%,
the portfolio return for that period would
simply be 0.5. So the weighting to one
stock times by 5%
plus 0.5 times 10% the weighting to the
other stock, which overall would give you
a performance of 7.5%.
Now that all sounds quite trivial so far,
but we do need to think about weightings a
little bit more
carefully before we get stuck in. And what
it basically comes down to is a decision
about
rebalancing. And this is where some of the
concepts that we talked about previously
come into play.
If we don't rebalance at all, then
basically what we're doing is calculating
portfolio performance for
a trade and hold strategy. Effectively, we
can figure out what the profit and loss
would have looked like
in a portfolio if we traded a certain
dollar amount in number of stocks and held
those positions for an
amount of time. Alternatively, we could
look at a portfolio that rebalances.
Rebalancing positions is
usually something that's associated more
with investing rather than trading. And so
in a sense,
this is a less practical way to measure
performance for us as traders, as I said
before. However,
what can be useful to us is to measure
portfolio performance based on an
assumption of constant
weights. The reason being that you can
then answer questions such as when the
portfolio has performed
well or poorly at any point in the past
based on those specific asset weightings
that you've outlined.
So as you've probably gathered, these are
exactly the same concepts that we've been
through already
previously with looking at non-rebalanced
performance versus constant weighting
performance in a long short
pair of stocks. So let's look now at
non-rebalanced portfolios first. If we
take a look at the portfolio NRB sheet,
you can see that there's a template
already laid out for you guys to use. And
there's a number of steps
to go through in this template just to get
the sheet working. But as you're going to
see, as we go
through some examples, it isn't that
difficult. So let me briefly outline what
we're going to do now.
Step one is to enter the tickers that you
want to be in the portfolio into row one
into the orange cells,
assuming that you already have the data
for those stocks updated and in their own
sheets within the
spreadsheet file. It's important that the
text that you enter into these cells
matches whatever the sheet
names are for the relevant company. So
that's why I suggest making the sheet
names for each company's data
equal to the ticker symbol. Step two is to
enter the number of shares for each
company into row two,
which effectively gives each position a
starting way in the portfolio. And then we
need to define whether the
position is a long or short position in
row five, in order to make the returns for
short positions
inverted if we need to. The next step,
step three, will be to enter a series of
dates into column A from row
11 down, which defines the period over
which we'll be measuring portfolio
performance. Step four is where
things become a little bit trickier
because I'm going to be teaching you some
quite complex Excel
functions and formulas in order to look up
prices for each stock on the relevant
dates. And put simply,
what these formulas are going to do is in
each cell, they'll reference the date seen
in the relevant
row as well as the ticker seen in the
relevant column, and then use those values
to pull through the correct
price data. And as a heads up, the formula
that we're going to be using is kind of
going to build upon
the VLOOKUP function that we used earlier.
Finally, step five will involve some more
calculations,
this time at the portfolio level, where
we'll calculate the dollar returns for
each period and
the overall portfolio value. Before we
start, let me just say that although the
calculations
at times might be a little bit daunting,
if you just take your time and break them
down,
they're really not that difficult. So even
if you do have trouble though, while we're
going through
this in the video, obviously you can, you
can pause the video, you can go back, look
at it as many times
as you need. But even if you are having
trouble with them, it doesn't actually
matter too much. All you
really need to be able to do is replicate
what I'm doing for your own analysis and
just understand what the
formulas aim to do rather than the
specifics of the formulas themselves. So
I'm going to go through a
worked example now to demonstrate how the
sheet works, where we calculate the
historical performance
for a $100,000 portfolio that contains 10
large and mega cap stocks of which six are
longs and four
are shorts. Before we begin, let me point
out that the longs and shorts that I'm
going to use in this
portfolio and in the examples ahead have
all performed pretty well in their own
right. So we can expect the
performance to be quite good. I've built
it specifically that way so that you guys
get an idea of what's
achievable when you build really good
portfolios yourselves. If you want to get
a quick rundown of
the companies that we're looking at when
you download this sheet yourselves, you
can just check out the
summary tab here that I showed you at the
beginning of the video as well. But for
the rest of the video,
I am going to mostly refer to the
companies just by their ticker rather than
their full names or
providing any more details about them just
because it will make it easier for the
video to flow.
Okay, so you can choose any stocks you
like by entering their ticker name into
the orange cells in the
first row. However, the calculations we
look at later will only work if you have
sheets containing price
data for each stock that you enter and
those sheets are actually named or have to
be named with the
appropriate ticker symbol. So again, as I
said earlier, the sheet names need to
match the tickers that
you put into these orange cells. In this
example, I've already entered the stocks
that we're going to
look at for the first portfolio by
entering their tickers in the orange cells
and you can see that
they all have sheet names matching them
with price data that's been updated to the
10th of June 2021.
In row two, what we're going to do is
calculate and enter the number of shares.
We're long or short
in each company based on a roughly equal
capital commitment to each position. And
then in row five,
I've chosen already whether the positions
themselves are longs or shorts by entering
a one for a long
position or a minus one for a short
position. And as I said before, all the
tickers in row one,
again, need to match name sheets that
contain price data for those relevant
stocks. And what you can see
in rows six and seven is the start and end
dates that have been automatically
calculated for each of
those stocks based on their time series in
their relevant sheets. So that's useful to
us because
it then allows the sheet to calculate the
shortest time series, assuming all the
data is up to date,
which is denoted by the ticker that
appears in cell B8. As I said previously,
whenever we're compiling
stock data from various companies, we need
to make sure that we're only using prices
on dates that are common
to all companies. And it's handy therefore
to know which the shortest time series of
data we have is,
because it acts as a starting point to
create a column of common dates. For
example, here you can
see the shortest time series is SPLK,
since that company came to market most
recently in April 2012.
Or at least that's the earliest data that
we have available from our data source,
which is Yahoo Finance.
So for any date before that price data for
SPLK is unavailable and therefore we
wouldn't be able to
calculate portfolio performance at that
time either or before that date. So the
earliest possible date that
we can use in this portfolio is actually
going to be the 19th of April 2012. For
this example though,
we're just going to calculate portfolio
performance from 2021 onwards. So I'm
going to go over to the
SPLK sheet now, since that's our shortest
time series, and then I'm going to copy
all of the dates
from 2021 onwards to the latest available
data, and then paste that into column A in
the portfolio NRB
performance sheet. I'm just going to do
that by manually scrolling to the earliest
date in 2021,
and then pressing control shifting down on
the keyboard to select all of the dates
after that,
and then copying them across, pasting them
into cell A11 of the portfolio NRB sheet.
Okay, now we need formulas that pull
prices through for all of these stocks and
on all of these dates.
And I'm going to start with pulling
through the price for EIX on the 4th of
January 2021 into cell B11.
And to do that in that cell, I'm going to
use a VLOOKUP function by typing equals
VLOOKUP. And as with
all Excel functions, we need to enter some
function parameters separated by commas
inside the brackets
after we've called the function that we
want to use. I know I've been through the
VLOOKUP function once
already with you in this video, but I'm
going to explain it again here, since it's
going to become
part of a larger formula that we're going
to use to retrieve prices in this sheet.
So I'm going to start
by selecting a cell for our first
parameter, which is basically the cell
that we want to look up. Okay,
that's going to be our date in cell A11.
So that's our reference that we want to
look up within another
table to then retrieve the price for EIX
on that date. So the lookup table, which
is the next parameter
in the function. So I've put in a comma
here and then gone to the next parameter.
The lookup table
is just going to be columns A to G in the
EIX sheet. And then again, we go to the
third parameter of the
function here. And I'm just going to type
in the number six because we want the
sixth column within
we want to basically return whatever is in
the sixth column within that lookup table
that we've just
defined. So that will be our adjusted
close prices. And then finally, putting
another comma and going to
the last parameter of the function, I'm
just going to type in false here. So it
just returns an exact match.
So just to go through that again briefly,
the first parameter here, A11, is a cell
reference to the
date that we want to look up in another
table. The second parameter defines the
table that we want
to find price data within that matches
that date. And when you do this, you need
to make sure that the
first column in the table contains the
values that you want to look up. So the
dates in this instance.
So that's why we're selecting from column
A to G, because A contains the dates and
G,
column G contains our adjusted close data.
The third parameter tells the function
which column to
retrieve data from once the row has been
defined by the lookup date. So the sixth
column in our formula
makes sure that the adjusted close prices
are returned for each date. And then
finally, the fourth
parameter should just be set to false
because we want to make sure that the date
that we look up
is an exact match in whatever sheet we're
looking in. So you can see there that the
value returned in
that cell is the adjusted close price for
EIX on that date. Now that formula is
pretty good and you can
copy it down to the end of the table and
it will work. However, you can't copy this
formula across to
other columns for a couple of reasons.
Firstly, none of the references in the
formula so far have been
fixed. So if we copy the formula across
one column, then instead of looking up
dates, the formula is
going to try and look up what we see in
column B, which is the prices that we've
just calculated for EIX.
Also, the lookup table references have
changed and are no longer referencing
columns A to G. So to
remedy these problems, we want to fix the
references to the lookup value to make
sure that the column
letter is fixed, but not the row number.
And also we want to fix the references to
the lookup table,
which we always want to be columns A to G
no matter what column we're in and what
sheet we're referencing.
So to fix a cell reference, we just add
dollar signs before the relevant cell
letter or number,
depending on whether you want to fix the
column letter reference or the row number
reference or
both. And in this example, that means
putting dollar signs before the column
letter for our date reference
and before the column letters for our
lookup table. Secondly, even with the cell
references fixed,
you can see that when the formula is
copied across, the price returned is the
same for IBM as it was for
EIX. That's because the lookup table was
still referencing the EIX sheet. Now to
fix this is a
little bit trickier. Basically, what we
need to do is substitute this second
parameter we've defined
here with some kind of dynamic reference
that changes the sheet name component of
the formula based on the
column that we're in. What I mean by this
is if the formula is in the EIX column, we
want it to
reference the EIX sheet to obtain prices.
But if it's in the IBM column, we want the
formula to reference
the IBM sheet for prices and so on. Don't
worry too much if you don't follow this
next part. Like I
said, you just need to be able to
replicate it. And as long as you
understand the general concept,
then it doesn't really matter if the
formula itself isn't fully understood. I
do warn you in advance,
so some parts of this will be hard to make
sense of purely just because they rely on
certain Excel
quirks. So the way I'm going to do this is
by building up a formula piece by piece to
replace
the second parameter of our VLOOKUP
formula, which is just the reference to
the lookup table. And just
so we're clear, the full lookup table
reference is basically this part here,
EIX, exclamation mark,
dollar A, colon dollar G, okay? So let me
write that out now into cell A9, just as a
reminder of
where we're trying to get to.
The lookup table reference that we have
here can be split into two parts, the
sheet name reference,
which is EIX, exclamation mark, and the
table reference within that sheet, which
is columns A to G.
Remember though, we're trying to make the
sheet name component dynamic so that it
changes depending
on whatever column we're in. Okay, I'm
going to use cell B9 now to build this
reference out with a
formula piece by piece. To start with,
creating a dynamic reference to the ticker
component of the
sheet name is pretty easy. All we need to
do is type equals B1, and that's going to
return the value of EIX,
which is the ticker that we see in cell
B1. And if we copy that across, it will
match whatever ticker
is seen in that column. However, we do
need to make sure that the row reference
is fixed so that no
matter how far we copy this formula down,
it always sticks to referencing the
tickers in row one. And we
can do that just by adding a dollar sign
before the row number, i.e. before the one
in this case.
Next, we need to add the exclamation mark
to complete the sheet name reference. And
to do this,
unfortunately, we can't just type an
exclamation mark in and put it on the end
of this reference
because Excel doesn't know what to do with
a cell that's equal to a reference to
multiple cells,
or as is the case here to a sheet name
without performing a function on it first.
Anyway,
what we can do, though, is turn this into
a text string. And then once we have the
formula completed,
we can turn it back into a reference. And
this is going to become a bit clearer as
we keep going.
So to add an exclamation mark here and
turn this formula into something that
outputs text,
we can add on an ampersand followed by an
exclamation mark within double quotation
marks.
And the ampersand is just used in Excel
formulas to link components of text
together, which means
that this formula is reading whatever is
in cell B1 as text and just adding on
whatever is inside the
quotation marks afterwards. So that makes
the next bit easy as well, which is just
adding in our table
reference. The table reference is the same
no matter what sheet we're in, because
every sheet
is laid out in exactly the same way with
price data from Yahoo Finance. I'm talking
about
our price data sheets here. So all of our
tickers down the bottom that we have as
sheet names.
So we can just add some more text in here
in our double quotation marks, which is
just going to be
equal to $a colon $g. And that's just the
column references to our lookup table that
we want to use,
as I kind of showed earlier in the VLOOKUP
function. Okay, so when I copy this across
now,
you can see that we've basically created
what we wanted initially just in text form
rather than as
a cell reference. All we need to do now is
turn this bit of text into a reference and
we can do that
using the indirect function. But first,
there is one final quirk of Excel that we
need to address,
which goes back to the sheet name
reference. Unfortunately, when we go
through the process
of turning a sheet name reference in Excel
into text, we need to actually surround
that reference
in single quotation marks. So what that
means here is that we need to link some
single quotation marks
with an ampersand to the outside of our
sheet name reference. And those single
quotation marks can only be
linked if they themselves are inside
double quotation marks. I know this sounds
bizarre, but hopefully
you'll see what I mean based on the output
that I'm getting here. So let's put that
formula into the
second parameter of our VLOOKUP formula
that we had applied earlier in cell B11.
And we're also going to
apply the indirect function on this kind
of second parameter text that we've
created. Remember what we
created just before was basically a
dynamic text string, and that needs to be
turned into something
that Excel can read as a table reference
for the lookup table component of this
VLOOKUP function.
And so that has to be done by using the
indirect function on that text string that
we've just created.
Okay, so that's the formula completed.
Like I said before, don't worry at all if
you didn't follow
that entirely. You only need to be able to
recreate it and understand what it
achieves to actually,
you know, make use of this stuff.
Incidentally though, a good tip I have for
you guys if you
create a formula and want to understand
more about how it works is to use the
evaluate formula button
in the formula tab on the ribbon. To
demonstrate this, if I select B11 now and
go to evaluate
formula, I can then click the evaluate
button and see the stages that the formula
goes through before
reaching its final output. And looking at
this now, you can see the first stage is
identifying the date
value in cell A11 and you can see this
turns into a serial number equal to 44200.
You don't need to
worry about that. It's just the date value
that Excel uses for the 4th of January
2021. After that,
it starts compiling the second parameter
of the VLOOKUP function, which is where we
entered the
indirect function inside the VLOOKUP
function. And as we step through, you'll
see that everything I added
into that part of the formula equates to
the same simple reference that I made
earlier, which is
columns A to G in the EIX sheet. And if
you keep going, we'll get to the value
that we now see in cell
B11. So the reason I went to all that
extra effort to create a dynamic reference
is that firstly, it now
allows us to copy that formula across as
far as we need to. But secondly, and more
importantly, it means
that we can change the tickers in the
orange cells at the top of the sheet and
the correct prices are
always going to pull through provided that
we have the data and that the sheet names
are named correctly
and set up correctly to match the tickers.
Okay. Now that we've got our dynamic price
references set
up and copied across every column as we
need to, we can also copy these formulas
down to the end of our
data set. And this is done simply by
selecting cells B11 to K11 in this case,
and double clicking the small
green box in the bottom right to auto fill
those formulas for every day. So with our
prices retrieved,
we can enter the number of shares we want
to be long or short in each stock now. And
as I said earlier,
we want a roughly equal weighted
portfolio, portfolio of positions with a
total gross exposure of about
$100,000. So the simplest way to calculate
the number of shares you need in each
position,
then is just by dividing the desired total
portfolio value by the number of
positions.
So that's 100,000 divided by 10, which
equals $10,000. So that's the sort of
exposure we want to each
position or the capital committed if you
like to each position position. And from
there, you just divide
that $10,000 by the share price at the
beginning of the model and round that to
the nearest whole number.
Since we're assuming that we can't trade
with fractional shares or anything like
that.
So in cell B2, I'm just going to type
equals round. So round is a function in
Excel that rounds a value to a certain
number of decimal places. So equals round,
open brackets, 10,000 divided by B11.
Okay. So the
first price that we have for EIX and then
comma zero, which means rounding whatever
that value is to
zero decimal places. So making it a whole
number. So just to reiterate that the
formula simply calculates
10,000 divided by the share price that
we've defined and then rounds it to the
nearest integer. And the round
function has two parameters, as you can
see, separated by a comma. The first one
is the value that you want
to round. And the second is the number of
decimal places that you wish to round to.
So once that
formula is entered, I can just copy it
across to get the number of shares for
each position. And we can see
that it roughly creates an equal weighted
portfolio with a value of $100,000.
What you'll also notice at this point is
that rows three and four have now been
populated as well.
Row three just calculates the starting
gross exposure in each stock, which is the
number of shares
multiplied by the first price that we see
in our table. And by design, it's
obviously very close to
$10,000 for every stock. Row four
calculates the starting gross weighting of
each stock given the
gross exposures above. And again, we chose
the number of shares we need to obtain an
equal
weighting. And so by definition, the
weightings for each of our 10 stocks are
going to be roughly
10% each. And by the way, it goes without
saying here that when you do any
backtesting yourselves,
you don't need to equal weight the
positions. You can actually choose any
position size that you want to
backtest. I just wanted to show you a
quick method in this example to get things
approximately equal
weighted, which we did with the rounding
function that we used previously. Okay,
everything that we
need for running some portfolio
calculations is now set up. So let's move
on to those. And what we're
going to do first is calculate the dollar
returns for each period. The concept here
is pretty simple.
All we need to do is add up the price
change for all of our longs multiplied by
the number of shares
and that will equal the total portfolio
returns in dollar terms. Now there's a
quick formula to
achieve this and I'll type this into cell
T12. Now it is equals some product and
bear with me with this
one. I'll explain it a little bit more
after, but it's equals some products.
That's the function that
we're going to use, open brackets. And
then within the parentheses, we're going
to type three parameters.
Okay, the first parameter, they're all
going to refer to cell ranges. The first
range is B12 to S12.
Then we're going to put a comma. The
second range is B2 to S2. And we're going
to fix that reference just by
pressing F4 on the keyboard until we've
got dollar signs around all the column
letters and row numbers.
And then we're going to put another comma
to move on to the third parameter of the
function
and reference another range, which is B5
to S5. Again, fixing all of those
references.
I'm then going to close the brackets for
that first sum product function. And then
I'm going to put in a
minus sign, so a subtraction sign, and
then do a very similar function again. So
sum product,
open brackets, this time row B, sorry, I
should say cell reference B11 to S11 in
the first parameter.
That's going to be a dynamic reference.
Then B2 to S2, which is going to be a
fixed reference.
And then in the third parameter, B5 to S5.
Again, a fixed reference.
So what this formula basically does is add
up the net exposure for each stock on the
5th of January
in the first sum product function, and
subtracts the sum of the net exposures on
the 4th of January.
And that basically yields a dollar change
for the entire portfolio. The net exposure
for each stock
is simply calculated by taking the price
multiplied by the number of shares
multiplied by one or minus one,
depending on whether it's a long or short
position, which you can see are the three
parameters inside
our sum product functions. And by the way,
the reason why the reference I've used
extends to column S,
even though we don't have ticker
references beyond column K, is just so
that we can really easily
create larger portfolios without having to
reprogram all of these formulas. So
basically,
what we're doing here is for every period,
we're adding up all the dollar changes for
all for our
long positions and subtracting all the
dollar changes for our short positions.
And that equation
yields the total dollar change for the
portfolio. The formula that I've used
there with some product
functions is just sort of a quicker method
of doing that. Okay, so with that formula
completed,
now we can copy it down and note that this
time we can't just double click the auto
fill box because
Excel doesn't know how far to copy the
formula down if there's no data in the
column next to it.
So we need to actually manually click and
drag the auto fill box as far down as we
need to,
which is to the final row in our dataset.
So now we've done that, we've got our
dollar returns completed.
It's easy to calculate a time series for
our portfolio value from those dollar
returns. So in cell U11,
we just start with our starting portfolio
value, which is the sum of our starting
gross exposure
for each position. And we can find that
value in cell T3. So I'm just going to put
in here this cell
U11, I'm going to make that equal to cell
T3. From there, the portfolio value
changes with the dollar
returns we calculated in column T. So to
calculate our portfolio value on the 5th
of January 2021,
we just take whatever the value was on the
4th of January, plus the dollar returns in
cell T12.
So that means cell U12 is going to be
equal to cell U11 plus cell T12. And
that's all there is to it.
We can simply copy this formula down to
the end of the dataset now, and then we've
finished our model.
If we take a look at the value of the
portfolio over this time period, we can
see that it performed
okay. It gained around $7,000 in 2021. And
7% isn't too bad in half a year, but the
performance
is somewhat limited by the volatility of
the stocks within the portfolio. And low
volatility is fairly
common for stocks like this that are large
or mega caps. And realistically, as
traders, we want to seek
out additional volatility because it
represents opportunity to drive up
profits. And if you guys
have done the introduction to professional
level trading masterclass, you guys will
know all about
this. But in a moment, I'm going to show
you what can happen when you add small
stocks to the portfolio
and substitute them in for some of the
larger cap stocks that we have. And then
in the next video as
well, we're going to be exploring
volatility in a little bit more detail.
Now I'm not going to go
into any more detail here in terms of
additional analysis on the portfolio that
we're looking at.
But of course, if you wanted to, you could
use the methods that I've shown previously
in the video
to calculate things like daily percentage
returns and indexed performance of this
portfolio,
as well as generating charts that plot the
portfolio's value over time. I'm not going
to do that now just
since we've already kind of covered that
and that will just be showing you
basically repeating
something that you guys already know how
to do. What I do want to do is point out a
couple of
practicalities when it comes to using this
sheet yourselves. I talked before about
the importance
of taking the extra time to set up these
dynamic formulas. And I just want to
reiterate that once
you've done all of that, you can simply
change any of the orange and blue cells in
the
calculations will just all adjust
automatically. For example, we could
change the number of shares in
EIX and make it a short position. And as
you can see here, you would then see the
portfolio returns
and the portfolio value adjust
accordingly. You can also, if you want,
remove stocks entirely from
the portfolio. And to do that, you just
clear the contents of the appropriate
cells. So the orange ticker
cell and the blue shares cell as well as
the whether it's a long or short. So you
just clear the contents
of all of those by pressing delete on the
keyboard once you've selected them. And
once you do that,
you also need to delete the formulas for
that stock from row 11 downwards. So all
the price retrieval
formulas, otherwise you'll get errors
there and that will affect the portfolio
calculations.
So I'll do that as well now for EIX. And
what you want to make sure of here is that
you don't delete
kind of any of the prebuilt formulas. And
those are in rows three, four, six, seven,
and eight.
So that's all you need to do to remove a
stock from the portfolio. Adding stocks is
just as simple.
In a blank column, you just enter the
ticker. So I'm just going to re-enter the
details that we had
for EIX here. So you can just enter the
ticker at the number of shares and whether
it was a long
or a short position as well. And then you
can just copy the formula across from an
adjacent column and
auto fill it down to the end of the
dataset. Now, when you guys download the
template file for this
video, it's going to have an example
already filled out in this sheet. So if
you want to start fresh,
then what I suggest you do is clear the
contents of all the orange and blue input
cells, as well as
all of the dates and all of the
calculation cells from row 13 downwards.
And the reason why I say row 13
down and not row 11 down is because then
you don't need to recreate the formulas
that we've been through
all over again. And instead you can just
copy them down and across the sheet as
much as is required.
From that point, we can just create a new
portfolio in any way that we want, as long
as we have the
underlying price sheets for each stock
that we wish to enter into the new
portfolio. So for example,
if we want to build a portfolio here for
2021 with only EIX, IBM and SYK in it, we
can do that as
follows. You just enter the tickers into
the top row into the orange cells and the
number of shares and
also designate whether those positions are
long or short. You do that by changing the
variables in the
blue input cells. You then would copy the
dates that you want from the sheet with
the shortest time series.
So in this example, that's SYK. You can
see that from the cell value B8. Then we
delete the unnecessary
formulas that are returning errors. In
this case, that's just from E11 to K12
because we don't have
tickers in those columns to retrieve
formulas for. And then you just copy the
formulas down for the three
stocks that we want to retrieve prices for
and do the same for the portfolio returns
and the portfolio
value columns as well. The same sort of
process can be used for changing the date
windows that you
want to use as well. Just make sure that
when you do that, you clear any error
cells. And of course,
as I said earlier, you'll need to have
appropriately named sheets that contain
the price data for the
relevant stocks in order for the data to
pull through properly. And remember, the
tickers you
enter into the orange cells must all have
their associated sheets or their own
associated sheets
with the same name. So with the ticker as
the sheet name. So before we move on to
looking at measuring
portfolio performance for a constantly
weighted portfolio, let's change the
previous large mega cap
portfolio that we looked at and replace
the longs with alternative mid cap stocks.
So in this example,
I'm going to change our previous longs,
which were EIX, IBM, SYK, VZ, TJX, and
NEM. And I'm going to
change those longs with mostly mid cap
companies. And the ones I'm going to
choose are FRPT. So I'm just
going to enter these into the portfolio
now. FRPT, WMS, AGCO, TTC, OGS, and ALGT.
And I'm going to keep the
same short positions as we had before. So
those are SPLK, VTRS, SYY, and BDX. We
want to make all of the
variables in this portfolio as consistent
as possible with the large cap one that we
looked at previously.
So it's kind of as comparable. So
basically we can compare them easily. The
only thing we're changing
obviously is the stocks themselves. So
we'll continue with analyzing the
performance over the year 2021.
And we need to make sure that each stock
has a roughly equal weight. So all of our
10 assets are
roughly equally weighted. And we'll use
the round function as before to calculate
the number of
shares for each position to kind of
maintain approximately even position
sizes. Before that
though, let's copy across all of these
price retrieval formulas to the relevant
rows and columns
using the autofill functionality that
we've been through a number of times.
Okay, so we've got our dates and prices
set up and the correct stocks filled in.
Now we just need to
calculate the position weightings, which
as I said, we'll do in the same way as
before with the round
function. So in cell B2, I'm just going to
type in equals round, open brackets,
10,000 divided by B11.
Okay, so the sort of capital allocation of
10,000 per stock divided by the price, the
starting price,
which we find in row 11. And then in the
second parameter of the round function,
we're just putting a
zero. So that's after the comma. And that
just means there's only going to return an
integer as I
described before. And then we can close
the brackets and enter that in. And then
that can just be copied
across as I showed you guys previously.
And you can see now that we have a roughly
comparable starting
portfolio value equating to about
$100,000. And before I forget, prior to
analyzing the performance
of this portfolio, we need to specify
whether the positions are longs or shorts.
So I'll just go through
row five now and assign a value of one to
the first six stocks because they're long
positions
and a value of minus one to the last four
positions, which are shorts. So if we take
a look at the value
of the portfolio now through 2021, you'll
see that it's a lot more volatile, but
also it performs very
well. And it increases from a starting
value of about $100,000 to around $118,000
by June,
which is 18%. And that's good going really
for a six month period, especially for a
portfolio that
isn't using leverage in any way. And of
course, those returns could be magnified
quite significantly
with the use of options or other leverage
products. For those of you that have done
the introduction to professional level
trading masterclass, this is going to be
nothing new,
and you will have expected a more volatile
portfolio portfolio with greater
opportunity.
As soon as I mentioned that we're going to
substitute in smaller cap stocks,
if you haven't done the IPLT, then no
worries, but you might find it useful
given what we're
discussing here. As I said previously,
we're also going to talk a lot more about
volatility in the
next video as well. So you'll get another
chance to deepen your understanding there
too.
Earlier in the video, I talked quite a lot
about outperformance and underperformance
when we were just
comparing two stocks. And typically, if
our long position went up more or down
less than our short
position, then the spread trade as a whole
performed well, assuming the weightings to
each position were
equal, of course. Now, the same rough
principle applies here in the sort of
portfolio level, you're
looking for the stocks that you're long to
outperform the stocks that you're short.
But realistically,
you're not just looking for
outperformance, you're looking for more
than that. And a key point to
realise here is that in order to build a
really successful portfolio, you're
basically trying to
fill it with awesome longs that go up and
awesome shorts that go down. It's as
simple as that. And if
you do that with a good mix of stocks and
the right amount of volatility, there's no
reason why the
results can't be quite as good as they are
here. Okay, let's look at a constantly
weighted portfolio
model now in the sheet portfolio CW
performance. This sheet is very, very
similar to the last one
that we looked at in terms of how it
works. The only difference is that it
assumes a constantly
weighted approach. And this is the
approach that you should use if you want
to test portfolio performance,
assuming a set weighting to each position
in the portfolio. And that weighting is to
be maintained
for the duration of the model's backtest.
Now, as I've said a few times now, this
might be a little
bit unrealistic if you don't want to
rebalance for every period that you're
looking at. But it is a good
test of the weightings that you define and
it will tell you how those weightings
performed at any point
in time through the historical dataset
that you're looking at. So the orange and
blue cells need to be
manually filled in as before, the
difference being this time that you apply
a gross weighting to each
stock rather than a specific number of
shares. And it goes without saying that
when you do this,
you need to make sure that your total
portfolio weight is 100% as calculated by
the cell T2,
which is just the sum of all the
individual weights that you enter into row
two into those blue cells.
Now, you can see that I've got a portfolio
ready to go here again.
With the same 10 large cap stocks that we
looked at in the first model for the, in
the first portfolio,
I should say, for the previous model. And
again, it's weighted equally.
Procedurally,
we start in exactly the same way when it
comes to analysing the performance of this
portfolio by
identifying the shortest time series and
choosing a date window to measure
performance between.
In this example, I'm going to calculate
performance from the year 2021 onwards so
we can create that date
window by copying all the dates from the
SPLK tab that are on or after the 1st of
January 2021 and pasting them into this
sheet.
Okay, so the major difference between this
sheet and the non-rebalanced portfolio
sheet is that instead of pulling through
prices for each stock,
we instead need to pull through returns.
And that basically means we need to add a
little bit more to the formulas that we
used previously.
I'm not going to spend too much time
explaining the formulas and functions here
because we've already done the hard part
in the previous sheet.
But if you think about how to calculate
returns in general, basically, you need to
know two prices for each
periodic calculation, the price from one
period and the price from the previous
period so that you can calculate the
percentage change between them.
So we need to start in cell B10 this time,
which isn't the first row, but intuitively
that makes sense because as I just said,
we need to know the price in the previous
period to work out the percentage change
for the current period.
Therefore, we have to start one period
ahead of our first data point when
calculating returns.
So in cell B10, I'm going to cheat a bit
and instead of typing the whole formula
out,
I'm just going to copy the price formula
that we created in the previous sheet by
selecting cell B11 in that sheet
and left clicking and dragging over the
text in the formula bar and then pressing
Ctrl C to copy it.
So this is basically the VLOOKUP function
with the indirect function within it.
I'm copying all of that.
Then I'm going to paste that text into the
formula bar with cell B10 selected in the
constant weighting
portfolio sheet and just change the
initial date lookup reference to the
correct row.
That will then retrieve the price for EIX
stock on that date.
However, the aim here is to calculate
returns.
And so we need to divide that price on
that date by the price on the previous
date and then subtract one.
Again, the quick way to do this is to copy
the same formula again and paste it with
Ctrl V,
this time after a division sign and change
it slightly so that it looks up the price
on the previous date,
which we can do simply by editing the date
lookup cell.
So now we have a formula which looks up
the date on the 5th of January and divides
it by the date on the 4th of January for
that stock.
And all we need to do from here to
calculate percentage returns over that
period is to subtract one from the whole
equation.
So I'm just putting a minus one at the end
of that equation.
And now we've got the returns for that
period.
As before, you can just auto fill this
formula across for all the columns with
tickers in them
and down for all of the available dates
that you're looking at.
Next up, we want to calculate the
portfolio returns.
And this time we're calculating them in
terms of percentages rather than absolute
dollars.
So to do this, you just need to compute
the weighted sum of all the individual
returns in the portfolio.
And to do that, we can use the sum product
formula again.
So in cell T10, I'm going to type equals
sum product, open brackets.
Then I'm going to select cells B10 to S10,
which is our first set of returns for the
first parameter of the function.
Then put in a comma.
In the second parameter, I'm going to
choose cells B2 to S2, which is our
weightings.
And I'm going to fix those references and
then put in a comma.
And then in the third parameter, I'm going
to select cells B3 to S3, which is the
definitions
of whether each position is a long or
short.
And again, I'm going to fix those
references and then close the brackets.
So this formula just takes each stock's
returns basically on the current date and
multiplies it
by one or minus one, depending on whether
it's a long or short position
respectively.
And then it multiplies it by its weighting
in the portfolio.
Those weighted returns are then summed
together to give the overall portfolio
return on that date.
And that sum product formula I've just
built there does all of that sort of in
one function.
Remember, though, that with the sum
product formulas in the previous model,
we had to make sure that the references to
the weightings and the long short cells
are fixed.
And that's the same in this case as well.
So that just basically means that we have
to have dollar signs around the relevant
column letters
and row numbers in those second and third
parameters of the function.
Now, just as before, we can copy this
formula down by clicking and dragging the
little green box
in the bottom right of the selection to
the end of the data series.
Finally, we can create a portfolio index
based on these returns,
and you can choose to start the index at
whatever value you like.
It's very common practice in finance to
start an index at 100,
but you might like to start it at a value
that represents something closer to a real
sum of money
that you want your trading book to be or
that it currently is,
whether that's $20,000, $100,000 or
whatever.
So in cell U9, for this example, I'm just
going to enter a value of 100,000 to start
the index
because it keeps things comparable to the
portfolios that we looked at in the other
model.
And from there, the index is calculated in
the same way
as it was for the constantly weighted two
stock portfolio that we looked at earlier
with the long FRPT and short DLTR
positions.
So in cell U10, then we just calculate the
new index value for each date
as the prior period's value multiplied by,
in brackets,
one plus the returns for the current
period, as you can see here.
Then that formula can also be autofilled
down to the end of the dataset.
Okay, if we skip to the end of the data
series here, you can see that the
performance isn't
dissimilar to the non-rebalanced model for
the same portfolio over this short
six-month period.
Essentially, this portfolio of long,
short, large caps hasn't done a whole lot,
it's gained about 7%.
But let's double check what happens when
we add mid caps into the mix in the same
way as we did
before, by replacing longs in the
portfolio. So all I'm going to do to do
that is type over the first
orange, first six orange cells with new
tickers, which are FRPT, WMS, AGCO, TTC,
OGS, and ALGT.
Again, if we look at the results, so the
portfolio value, we can see they're quite
similar to the
previous model, what the previous model
showed for this portfolio. We see a much
better performance
in small caps than large caps again,
equating to a portfolio value in June of
around $119,000
using this model, which equals a
performance of around 19% over the period.
A couple of notes though about this
modeling method. Firstly, there is a
slight difference in the
inference of a portfolio like this to
using constant equal weightings to just
two stocks,
one long and one short, as we did earlier.
The reason is with this portfolio, we
can't say for sure
that our longs outperformed our shorts,
because even though each stock has been
equally weighted,
the portfolio weightings to longs overall
is 60% and only 40% to shorts. So,
strictly speaking,
this sheet just models how the portfolio
would perform at any point in time, given
those weightings
that you've applied. It doesn't
necessarily show you that your longs have
outperformed your shorts and
vice versa. Now, in this case, we can
intuitively assume that the longs have
outperformed the shorts
because the portfolio portfolio has done
so well over the period. But I'm just
trying to teach some
mathematical rigor here by saying that
just because the portfolio goes up in
value, doesn't always
guarantee your longs are outperforming
your shorts when you don't have an equal
weighting to the long
and short sides of the portfolio. The
other thing to note, which is more
generally about the difference
between the two modeling methods we looked
at, is that for the portfolio setups we've
used here,
there isn't much of a difference between
the model's performance, even though you
might have been
expecting that there would be, given what
we covered previously, with the FRPT-DLTR
pair.
This is for two reasons, basically.
Firstly, the weighting started off roughly
equal in both models.
But secondly, and much more importantly,
the historical performance that we
analysed was over a
relatively short period of time, where
there wasn't much time for the weightings
in the portfolio to
drift from their starting point. And if
you remember back to the FRPT-DLTR spread
example,
the weighting to FRPT did eventually drift
from 50% to 85%, but that took seven
years. And we're only
looking at a period of six months here.
Okay, so that's all there is to using the
constant equal,
sorry, constant weighted portfolio
performance sheet. And as I said, it's
very similar to the
previous one in mechanics. And all the
previous tips that I gave you about
editing the sheet and
modelling your own portfolios apply in
exactly the same way here. And as I said,
for the last sheet,
there's no reason why you can't do things
like create a chart for the portfolio
index. And you
know, you guys know how to do that based
on the charting section that we covered
earlier near the
beginning of the video. So with regards to
both these portfolio models we looked at,
the idea here is
that you can build and understand the
historic performance of whatever portfolio
you want.
Obviously, these models are somewhat
simplified to what real portfolios might
look like. For example,
there's no account here for trading costs,
currency conversion, or cash positions, or
even sort of
changing the weightings in the positions
as you kind of go through the date series.
But nonetheless,
it can be useful to run these simulations
when you want to see how a portfolio of
stocks might fit
together. And just to get an insight into
how your current or prospective portfolio
set up performed
historically. Because if it hasn't
performed well in the recent past, you
have to question, you know,
what makes you think that it will in the
near future. And you need to ask yourself
those questions
to make sure that you have a good
fundamental reason or many good
fundamental reasons, along with
technical timing to give yourself the best
shot of making money in the portfolio.
Okay guys, we've made it. Let me just wrap
up the video now with a reminder of what
we've covered
and some concluding remarks about what you
guys need to take away from the tutorial.
So we started with downloading stock price
data from Yahoo Finance into Excel and
then charting that data.
And I mentioned how you need to be
flexible with your approach to sourcing
data with regards to the
sources themselves and to the data series
that you use. And basically what that
means is you need to
make sure that you always understand what
the data represents and ensure that it's
fit for purpose for
the analysis that you're doing. A good
example of that was in this video when we
noted the difference
between the closing and just closing
prices from Yahoo Finance. And we verified
that both are actually
applicable to the analysis that we wanted
to do, but one was preferable.
We then moved on to charting and I showed
you how you can experiment with formatting
charts to
any sort of style that you like. And I
also showed some tricks about prepping the
chart to auto-update
whenever you input more data into a sheet.
We also touched a little bit on how you
can use some Excel tools to
do some basic technical analysis and
things such as plotting, moving averages
and trend lines.
Next up, we covered various measures for
assessing the performance of a long short
pair trade.
Ratio calculations are quick and simple to
use, but they don't necessarily provide a
completely
accurate picture of performance, whilst
spread calculations are accurate but
inflexible when it
comes to weightings. So if you want to use
measures that are both precise and
flexible,
then you have to use what are essentially
portfolio calculations, which is what we
turn to next,
where we treated our two positions, the
long and the short, as a mini portfolio.
To do this, we generated returns for each
stock position and combined them to yield
the overall
performance of that mini portfolio. And
this was done in slightly different ways
depending on whether we
used a constant equally weighted approach
or a non-rebalanced approach. And both of
these methods
have their uses. So while the constant
equal weighting calculation is perhaps a
fairer way to measure out
performance at any given time in a long
short pair, it is less practical since it
implies constant
rebalancing, which is probably quite
unrealistic in most scenarios. That's why
we then also looked at a
non-rebalanced approach as well, which
gives you a more accurate picture of
performance given you hold
the two positions over a period of time.
Both methods are valid and it really
depends on what you're
trying to model and why as to which one
you end up using. We then looked at
comparing all the performance
measurements up to that point to clear up
what the differences were and why they
exist. So that was
done in the comparison tab of the sheet.
Finally, we moved on to a full portfolio
performance calculations,
which were just an extension really of
what we'd already covered. Again, we
looked at constant
weighting and non-rebalancing models so
you can build a fuller picture of the
historical performance
of any portfolios that you want, provided
that you can get the data. And this is
useful because
it gives us an insight into how our
current or prospective portfolio setups
have performed in the
recent past. And that should then prompt
questions about whether you expect the
performance of the
portfolio to change or stay the same and
why. Now, of course, the models that we've
been through here
are simple. They don't account for things
like trading costs or currency conversion
or cash
positions and things like that. But the
idea here was really to show you that a
long short portfolio is
just a scaled up version of a long short
spread trade. And what we're trying to do
is build portfolios
where our longs outperform our shorts on a
one to three month timeframe and positions
go in and out of
the portfolio. Ideally, we want awesome
longs that go up and awesome shorts that
go down. And if we do
that in a well-built portfolio with proper
risk control, there's lots of money to be
made as I kind
of showed in some examples that we went
through. And speaking of those examples, I
also made a point of
showing you what can happen if you add in
smaller cap companies to a portfolio,
which is that it typically
results in more volatility and hence more
opportunity for profit. And what this
basically leads onto is
the conclusion that we can aim for the
level of volatility and risk that we want
in the portfolio.
And this is something we're going to
explore more in the next video where I'm
going to talk in more
detail about portfolio volatility and how
we can calculate it.